エイジ：YouTuberとは
動画投稿サイトYouTubeに動画を投稿し
現在、ネット上だけでは留まらず
多くの人たちの注目を浴びている
彼らは好きな動画を撮って
なにするんですか、、、
彼らは、、、、うふふふ
はじめ：早く！早く！
エイジ：はい、分かりました(笑)
えーっと
はじめ：ねーえー
エイジ：ひらがなが(原稿に)多いんですよ
はじめ：分かった分かった分かってないw
エイジ：楽しんでいるだ、け、のように見えるが、、、
彼らは好きな動画を撮って
楽しんでいるだけのように見えるが
彼らの本当の姿は
果たして、、、
はじめ：(ナレーション)いいんじゃない？
はじめ：こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーと！
エイジ：アバンティーズのエイジと
リクヲ：リクヲと
そらちぃ：そらちぃと
ツリメ：ツリメです
はじめ：はいどうも、やってきましたー！
皆さんわざわざ静岡までね
はじめ：はい、という訳で
実家に弟が帰ってたんですけども
今、静岡まで帰って来る途中でございます
で、もうすぐ来るんですけども
弟から見ると
やっぱYouTuberとか
YouTubeの世界って
明るいものだと思ってるんですよ、今
動画出して
ヘラヘラ笑って
楽しいな YouTube、みたいな
YouTuberいいなぁ、みたいな
ってなってるらしいんですけど
もっとYouTubeを
闇深いものだと感じて欲しい、俺は
はじめ：あんな甘い世界じゃない
っていうのを伝えたいなと
リクヲ・そらちぃ：なるほど～
はじめ：YouTubeのね、闇の部分を
見せてあげて
(弟が家に)入って来た時に
僕がアバンティーズを全裸で
シバいてると
弟はいったい兄のその姿を見て
どう思うのか
検証していきたいと思います
5人：あはははは(笑)
はじめ：ねーーーーっ！
はじめ：やることに意味があると思ってるんで
エイジ：やってみないと分からない
はじめ：やってみないと分からない
それを見て弟は
アバンティーズに
入りたいって言うかもしれない
もしかしたら
ツリメ：交わるかもしれない
はじめ：アバンティーズ5人になるかもよ
そこで、ひょっとしたら
はじめ：おらぁ！
おい！@;/;``+`?{
アバンティーズ：わぁ！すみませんー！わー！
わーわー
はじめ：おらぁ！足んねぇぞ！！！
おらぁ！
アバンティーズ：痛い！ギャーー！わーー！
ツリメ：あーーーん
そらちぃ：うわぁ
エイジ：うわっっっ！
リクヲ：うあ！
はじめ：こういうのが欲しいんだろ
アバンティーズ：うわっ！
はじめ：なぁ、お前ら
ツリメ：あーーー！
そらちぃ：うわーーー！
リクヲ：えっ！
うふふふふ
エイジ：うわっふ
そらちぃ：いたたたた
リクヲ：うわぁ！
ううう
アバンティーズ：うわぁ！
うわぁ！
痛い！
あぁ！
あ！あ！あ！あ！
あぁ、どうもー
初めまして、よろしくお願いします
<字幕の閲覧ありがとうございました！>
弟：はじめまして
はじめ：とりあえず飯でも行くか
一同：あはははは(笑)
エイジ：まじかよー
あぁ！小指打った
弟：びっくりしたー！